Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody, hope everybody
had a good weekend. Much to discuss, so let's get
right into it. We have now a more public battle,
essentially between the most centrist, or some
would call it right wing wing of the Democratic
Party, meaning Joe Manchin from West Virginia
and Bernie Sanders more the left wing of the
Democratic Party. And Bernie has basically had it
up to here with Joe Manchin and wrote an op ed Not
Just Anywhere mentioning Joe Manchin, but actually
wrote it in a local paper to Joe Manchin in West
Virginia, which we're going to look at. Written
in the Charleston Gazette Mail. Bernie wrote an op
ed saying, Let's stand together to protect working
families. We're going to look at the op ed and
we're going to look at Joe Manchin's response.
Manchin very, very triggered that Bernie is doing
this. So let's get right into it. Bernie writing
in America today, the very rich are becoming
richer, while millions of working families are
struggling to put food on the table or pay
their billsolin po. We now have the absurd
situation in which two multi-billionaires own more
wealth than the bottom 40 percent of Americans
going on to say the $3.5 trillion build back
better bill supported by President Biden and
almost all Dems in Congress is an unprecedented
effort to finally address the long neglected
crises facing working families and demand that
the wealthiest people and largest corporations
in the country start paying their fair share of
taxes. In fact, this legislation would be paid
for by ending loopholes and raising taxes on the
one percent and large, profitable corporations.
The bill would take on the breed of greed of the
pharmaceutical industry. Last year alone, while
one out of four Americans could not afford to
fill prescriptions. Six pharmaceutical companies
made nearly 50 billion in profits, and the 10
highest paid executives made over 500 million
in compensation. Bernie extolls The virtues of
what's proposed The bill would expand Medicare.
The United States and states like West Virginia
and Vermont in particular are seeing populations
age, meaning more older Americans and people
with disabilities needing home health care.
The build back better plan is not only vitally
important for seniors, but is enormously important
for working families and children. As a result of
the $300 direct payments to working class parents,
which started with the American Rescue Plan,
we've cut childhood poverty in our country
by half. It would be unconscionable to see
those payments end, which is what will happen
if we don't pass the bill and Bernie going on
explaining all of the great things that the bill
actually does. It makes investment in
housing. We would reduce homelessness
and then it would to some degree deal with climate
change. It would create jobs. And Bernie says this
is being opposed by every Republican in Congress,
as well as drug companies, insurance companies,
the fossil fuel industry and the billionaires.
They want to keep the status quo. And Bernie
says it's now time to do this. And then he says
there is overwhelming support for the legislation,
which there is and yet, writes Bernie. The
political problem we face is that in a 50-50
Senate, we need every Democratic senator to vote
yes. We now only have 48. Two Democratic senators
remain in opposition, including Senator
Joe Manchin, a Democrat of West Virginia.
This is directly and accurately calling out Joe
Manchin and Kirsten Cinema, although this was in
a West Virginia paper, this is focused on Manchin
for his unwillingness to just do the right thing
for his own constituents, which I will remind
you about with some statistics in a moment. Joe
Manchin is not pleased that Bernie did this. Joe
Manchin has responded in typical, Joe Manchin is
saying this isn't the first time an out of
stater has tried to tell West Virginians
what's best for them, despite having no
relationship to our state. I would argue
by virtue of understanding the dynamics of
Vermont. That Bernie Sanders actually far better
understands the situation for West Virginians than
does Joe Manchin, but understand that this is not
substantive. This is Joe Manchin saying Get off my
lawn, Bernie. Get off any lawn in West Virginia.
Manchin writes millions of jobs are open, which
is ignores the fact that wait, hold on. What jobs,
what do they pay? What are the conditions? Supply
chains are strained and unavoidable. Inflation
taxes are draining workers hard earned wages as
the price of gas and groceries goes up sounds
like a Republican. Senator Sanders answer
is throw money on an overheated economy,
while 52 other senators have concerns. To be
clear, Congress should proceed with caution
on any additional spending. I will not vote for a
reckless expansion of government programs. What do
I think this is fundamentally about? Joe Manchin
spent months saying the problem is the price tag
is too big for these infrastructure bills, and
then Democrats came to the table and said, OK,
we can lower the price that we get, we can reduce
this and then we'll fix that problem, right, Joe.
And then Joe says, Well, now because a lot of the
stuff that's in here aren't things we should be
spending money on. Like, for example, the climate
crisis at this point. Is it just about Joe Manchin
personal financial interests? Like is it? Is it
that simple? Joe Manchin gets $500000 a year,
thanks to records obtained by Alex Koch for the
Center for Media and Democracy and published
by The Guardian. Manchin makes roughly half a
million a year in dividends from millions of
dollars in coal company stock that he owns. The
stock is held in energy systems. That's a company
Manchin started in 1988 and later gave to his son
to run. Joe Manchin received a ton of money from
fossil fuel lobbyist groups and donors who usually
donate to Republicans but seem willing to donate
to Joe Manchin because of his position on these
issues. So I don't want to be reductionist and say
it's just his pocket. Maybe it is. Maybe it is.
And maybe that's why Joe Manchin is taking these
positions. As I've said before, West Virginia is
a disaster and needs help, not an attack on the
people. West Virginia. Just look at the data is
a disaster. Terrible unemployment rate, terrible
health care. West Virginia is ranked 47th out of
50th in the country in health care. That means
access, quality and public health are terrible on
education. West Virginia's ranked 45th out of 50
in terms of education that includes higher ED
and pre K through 12. As far as infrastructure is
concerned, West Virginia is dead last 50th based
on energy, internet access and transportation.
West Virginia, like few places in this country,
desperately needs this bill and they've got Joe
Manchin now. If they had a Republican, I
know, I know, guys, if it was a Republican
instead of Joe Manchin in the Senate, he's not
voting. He or she is not voting for it anyway.
But this is a state that desperately needs
this, and now Bernie, taking it directly to
Joe Manchin and Joe Manchin doesn't like it.
Will it change what Manchin ultimately does?
I don't know. We'll talk more about that
tomorrow and what's currently on the table.